[Music]
it's time ladies and women to get your
dab on because you guys have straight-up
been tugging up some sick sick a beep
sister girl
what you been cooking a straight up in
list okay last week I asked you to I had
a shitty file of music I basically
recorded for five minutes and I asked
you guys to to mix it to something hella
slammin so let's see how you guys
perform expect the women never black
respect the women everybody Oh respect
the women everybody respect the women
everybody everybody break it break it
break down down down down down down down
down down down
I'm out break break it right now girl no
down down down down pretty good pretty
good
Adisa shred sir my name is Nick and
Michael at bass coming yes I gave back
and show another [ __ ] tingling in my
baby and you know what we started yeah
Wow
I
[Music]
Holloway I didn't expect different
genres and [ __ ]
usually it's all like [ __ ] dance and
[ __ ] [ __ ] heavy heavy rock or
whatever it's called I don't know
okay great 25:25 but I still got paid
anyway pretty fine
Jenny but can but I still got paid
anyway campaign anyway you're damaged so
disappointed
am i guilty of the same time got a very
adamant feeling I have my computer my
eyes like our budget dog because she
only had one eye it's gonna be the most
boring Michael boring my book dude I had
a rhyme perfect hey what's a sex but I
do
anyway
25 can rebut and but I know your name
[ __ ] good and ego also respects women
so much that he looks like one that's
impressive
respect Hammond respect one respect when
respect maybe I should have spent a
little bit more time on the multiply man
everybody [ __ ] doing respecting women
welcome to the [ __ ] to get your boys do
you PI o kill me
no my Chum will never die yes no more
ideas no original content but we're not
[ __ ] long you know it with content so
welcome to the family I'm your daddy now
I'll make you like you lose to love
don't be [ __ ] rich
they call me nasty specimen ding my
[ __ ] fur oh oh um pretty spots the
greatest on a seven yeah i ball drops
dippin and drop nectar flow is so off
okay see if you guys didn't see this
lush sucks actually painted a tweet with
my picture on it he asked me for a
selfie so I sent the one from my stay
last week submission and he actually put
it on it but in Museum in Vienna it's
pretty good if you're in Vienna you
should check it out
thanks again lush sucks that fills my
ego to have my head that big it really
helps a lot thank you
PewDiePie
[Music]
Oh welcome to your boy hey now my
channel never die everybody if I can't
rap no one from England s my CD and you
know I don't get good [ __ ] man talking
ok
I don't know what Wow anyway Wow today's
another day to find you go away
that's I'll be coming for your level
[Music]
me
okay all right that was really good I'm
really proud of you guys my name is Nick
Compton in my collects a topic you like
hate right no I'm not from Compton
flying like this my PT and you know I'm
[Music]
what
0:04 nation it's everyday bro okay
pretty pretty tight man
pretty pretty late I would say very well
done well done you can break it down now
girl
ah
related to find
[Music]
respect respect respect web risk 7m
respect to Y and applied to this issue
is your boy through tight you can't tell
me no my channel never died hey no more
idea
no original content but when your mom
you know is with confidence the family
mom you're getting out [ __ ] I'll make
you mine you'll live until I'm filthy
[ __ ] rich
hey this is the day my [ __ ] birthday
Italian just dropped on you merge and
it's selling like a garage yeah that's
pretty [ __ ] good I really like that
one
well done pretty class their greatest Oh
ripping gasps my balls will drop them
sipping and your eyes disrespecting
women nothing's [ __ ] cop they're
British mother ripping my balls will
drop sniffing and your heart
disrespecting Clemens nothing in it
smelling like God
break it down now girl
this is getting really [ __ ] get are
you paying today's theme respect wagon
respect respect respect women respect
man my grandma really respect kratom a
woman's respect man respect women
respect respect respect respect respect
respect respect respect women respect
women Chris back when we've always good
[ __ ] from day by day
they're clearly taking my name shoving
it into the ground just to get back the
maniac their steady [ __ ] well to the
[ __ ] with you boy Judy pie
yeah tell me how much you'll never die
no more ideas I'm your daddy now [ __ ]
Oh make you like you look till a [ __ ]
[ __ ] rich they call me
[Music]
Wow
my religion or try Ella type hella
tight' we only have three left Bros boy
so my devil never died
yeah boy no original content so what is
it an outrage I mean you must give up to
be [ __ ] rich they probably burn
[Music]
[Applause]
this is smooth as [ __ ]
[Music]
take me
you
I would get like that [ __ ] dope
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and it's ready it's everyday liver
it's average age with study that makes
Compton and McCulloch state puppets
yes I can't rap and no I'm not from
Compton tinglin is my CD and you know
I'm restarted everybody knows that make
one's own integrated to deposit greatest
mother flippin guy my boss will drop
dippin and your eyes disrespecting women
no thanks v GD their greatest 7 -
respect
Grameen respect respect web respect
respect respect the whamon to provide my
name Jeff ha ha Oh
Grande appreciate it man good [ __ ] I
heard this song before it's [ __ ] good
it's really [ __ ] good like I listened
to this on ironically I think it's made
by a French youtuber is every day Bronk
you're gonna break out your boy
times you can't kill me like that oh
it's no original concept I went after
your mom you know in the convent which
is no greater mother women gasp the
greatest mother yes ma'am
related to science brilliant science and
buddy good news rat man how did you
create related to science brilliant
science just sign in page respect
[Music]
respect respect I get emotional I quit
my job my name's Michelle my name I just
know yet
it's all [ __ ] Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeff
[Music]
chairman related to science brilliant
science I love it so [ __ ] good
seriously everyone is submitted if you
were to make it I'm sorry I can't show
them all but legit so much fun I love
doing these I hope you guys enjoyed it I
hope you subscribe and enjoy it as well
for next week I want you to post a title
and a picture with Clickbank okay that
is the most clicks great thing you can
come up with pewdiepie related good good
luck you're basically doing all my work
from now on that that's what's happening
the most meme tastic ones will be
previewed in the next episode of
but that's it for now thank you both so
much I mean thank you sister so much
love you guys buy all my merch